mais est venu à sans filtre le podcast
on parle de ce qu'on veut que nos
invités
datsyuk ph cantagoy dôme plantes
aujourd'hui pas de carton a reçu marième
qui est une personnalité publique
animatrice chanteuse musicienne qui est
la porte parole du mois de l'histoire
des noirs qui le mois de février
alors on a parlé de la pertinence
d'avoir un mot l'histoire des noirs
la question du racisme des questions
qu'on ne débatte dans le dernier moore
le spectacle slave la progression
culturel tous eu également à sa carrière
musicale commence à vous sur quoi ils
travaillent à ce moment une belle
rencontre marie m et un beau pas de
castres ouais si vous aimez le sans-fil
podcast pu encourager sur notre
plateforme pétrole pétrole vous abonner
et vous avez accès à du contenu exclusif
qu'on vous offre le plus souvent
possible donc l'allier pour l'ap hp
turinois dans des fonctions de la vidéo
sinon abonnez-vous à notre chaîne
youtube pour avoir des notifications à
chaque fois qu'on sort un nouveau
podcast puis aussi en commentaire le
sait ce que vous vos impressions la
discussion et c'est ce que vous voulez
le si ce que vous voulez mais on a eu un
petit pan technique durant le podcast de
haut niveau du son vous allez vous en
compte sûrement mais perdez pas la
discussion de vue pour autant
sur ce bonne écoute mon podcast
mariam à l'eau bienvenue merci merci
d'être leur est gentil c'est une année
2010 9,3 comment cela la brutale tout
perdre quand on est juste au dessus
ouais ouais ça vaux bien tel parce qu'on
choisit nos vies un ouais bah oui c'est
exact mais exact puis fêtes d'enfants le
nous on va parler évidemment du mois de
février le mois de l'histoire des noirs
pour lequel tu es co porte parole
est ce que commencent à arriver ça a été
proposée web on m'a proposé si quelque
chose qui m'intéressait de représenter
le mode histoire des noirs comme porte
parole francophone est aussi un
porte-parole anglophone pat bowlen une
balade beaucoup puis ça me rend du super
fier quand on m'a demandé ça parce que
si j'ai quand même regardé j'ai zappé ça
veut dire que le parcours que j'ai fait
vaut maintenant le titre de porte parole
parce que ça veut dire que tu dis un
modèle en quelque sorte oui c'est un peu
ce que j'ai essayé de faire je pense
sans le savoir des machines et doit par
sénégalais d'une mare québécoise du
grand animal ou le quartier limoilou
l'été à québec est une ville douce bonne
qualité ville de québec - la diversité
il n'y en avait pas tant que ça quand
j'étais jeune des fois on n'était que de
noirs dans notre école primaire de
effectué rapidement mes parents nous ont
dit on va vous regardez vous allez de
pointé du doigt vous êtes différents
métiers embrassé cette différence l'aps
est d'une richesse travailler sur votre
personnalité puis faites ce que vous
voulez notre avis text of plus je pense
que sans le vouloir j'ai fait j'ai foncé
j'ai fait des choix puis à ce moment là
je me reconnaissais pas dans la tnt ni
la télé ni dans les médias n'est rien
jeter le ce pôle québec d'aujourd'hui
c'est qu'une des figures noires qui
avait tellement de gens que j'aime varda
n'avait pas chaud et kahn avait pas tant
que ça puis je mens je me suis je me
suis dit à ce moment là mais je pourrais
peut-être devenir humblement modèle qui
a lancé les exiger un peu toujours pour
ce mot oui oui je pense d'avoir voulu
simplement donner un modèle en faisant
la télé et j'ai commencé mais j'ai fait
un bac en communication après j'ai
partie ma boîte de thon bas qui le fait
ou
ouais comme questions publiques
n'étaient pas en télé je pense j'ai fait
publicité sociale à ce moment là j'ai
pour les changements de comportements
sociaux et aidant même pavillon casault
la ville a fait communication pierre est
à peu près de 40 kg quel âge c'est sa
demande pauvres qui m'a fait un petit
peu plus jeune que toi même de tout de
même crosse de traîtres qui ont pigé à
ce moment là une émission ray pop qui
sape les acheter du son ashes je me sens
aussi que francis dupeyron qu'avait
partition de partir de boîtes et les
produits sont quatre éléments en effet
tht qui sont tv après sa musique plus
cherché j'ai fait l'émission et pops de
fac
de fil en aiguille j'ai fait mon chemin
en télé lui finalement mais j'étais
encore le nouvel abouti oui c'est ça
parallèlement mais j'ai toute ma
carrière de musique que j'ai faite
comprend par les excès sont je pense que
quand on me le demande et j'étais fier
désormais coup donc j'ai fait une coupe
de bonnes affaires qui sont maintenant
considéré comme un modèle pour pour être
porte parole chinois huawei c'est super
cool ça va être un espèce de jeu je peux
dire tape dans le dos mais un espèce de
bons reconnaissance il moqué chercher
une reconnaissance pour pour une oeuvre
en constante évolution
le vix ouest pour le travail travail
accompli mais je travaille beaucoup avec
les jeunes
j'ai lancé une conférence dans les
écoles s'appelle les nouveaux modèles
il ya deux ans justement fait quand même
une star chez pour l'instant de
migration jeudi les jeunes n'ont pas de
modèle je trouve que léon l'on remonte
pas des modèles à qui peuvent relater
qui peuvent s'inspirer dans les écoles
par le fait que j'ai monté la mise
l'immigration c'est madame verts à
l'époque j'écoutais je voyais dans les
écoles je vais avoir des modèles fax
beau et parfait montrant votre projet fx
avait pris deux ans normalement virer
vers là ils m'ont envoyé par la ville de
québec avait un appel d'offres tout ça
fait que j'ai présenté mon projet ça
fonctionne et que j'ai fait quinze
écoles à québec accompagné le modèle fat
moi je parle de mon parcours puis
j'aimais ton éric martel bonifié par
litre carrière de boxeur puis celui ci
puisque c'est qu'est-ce qui fait pour
avancer
qu'est ce qui motive dans la vie puis
j'ai eu j'ai donc mené mettons j'ai une
jeune fille placide acquis et tarder
comme réfugiés une rentrée fichier qui
parlait pas français comme un finir bac
en littérature permettre aux
entrepreneurs en fait tout des histoires
sont inspirantes
mais pas nécessairement des vedettes moi
je veux que ça soit autant actuaires
ivoiriens que comptable vietnam est
juste montrer des exemples la diversité
font par sa société québécoise puis
auquel les jeunes peuvent s'inspirer
j'imagine avons un échantillon le plus
diversifié possible ça oui la première
le premier volet que j'ai fait quinze
écoles c'est beaucoup d écoles ou qui
avait une clientèle ciblée que beaucoup
de communautés culturelles le gène avoir
le goût pour le deuxième volet je
m'apprête à faire d'autres écoles encore
dans la région québec c'est vraiment et
c'est vraiment une bonne idée surtout à
québec week je trouve que ça manque et
on en parlait juste utilisé au début tu
sais c'est ultra homogène puis c'est
rare qu'on voit des exemples de réussite
oui ne sait pour l'heure pour la
diversité en fait c'était quoi la
réception que saab et ses six ateliers
le rsa trouviez marché en religion des
dix jeux les options primaire qu'au
secondaire que j'ai fait tout ça louis
joly
c'est magique ce que ça crie parce que
c'est super baiser que c'est juste un
spi rationnelle et je veux laisser la
personne qui parle pas de son parcours
mois devant les jeunes il pose toutes
les questions qu'ils veulent mais je
vois que ça marche c'est qu'on sème
quelque chose moi aussi j'ai juste fait
un petit os à ceux où j'ai espoir que
c'est possible d'être louis chanteuse un
artiste un athlète ou un entrepreneur
juste si je trouve ça crie quelque chose
ça fait naître de quoi plus professeur
me disais c'est nous on a besoin de ça
les multiples on s'en rappelle centre
des conférences ou des marchés qu'on
était plus jeune des gens que ça se
trouve que comme le lion la flamme pics
sont inspirants puis ça marche super
bien et puis mes juges délai de
recommandations des écoles musées pour
venez on va vous montrer au secondaire
500 marques après que je peux j'ai envie
de le faire partout les juifs et à
québec mais à montréal sont réalité mais
c'est je veux absolument tous ces morts
aviez-vous des feedback instantané des
jeunes parce que les jeunes venez vous
voir que vous donnez oui non il faut
aussi qu'elle était un peu gêné poseurs
quels souvenirs puisque je fais des
questions à tout le monde c'est quoi la
réaction mettons c'est qu'aulas est apte
à leur bouche mais ton apaisant satie ça
se peut faire de la télé moi j'ai des
jeunes filles travaillant télé que j'y
fais des formations ateliers mes
informations à montréal pimms et 1,8 et
aux personnes te demander de changer la
coupe de cheveux win this way parce que
c'est une grande considération certaines
personnes sur la diversité ce que tu vas
voir l'air est ce que tu souhaites
accepter ce que ça veut dire au moins
appeler ces faits relatés qu'un flot des
mots j'ai décidé que j'ai regardé
c'était moi puisque je ça vous êtes
parties de ma personne puis dans la vie
on peut pas faire tout on peut pas
toutes être pareil parce qu'on se repose
gagnant puisque pas maintenant régissant
vos personnes enfin que y'avait il y
avait sur la couleur de peau il y avait
bel et les défis qu est ce qui fait
qu'on lâche pas qu'est ce qui fait que
tu aies même si ce fait dire notre
continue à avancer fait que les jeunes
c'est beaucoup des questions comme ça
dans les fausses indications des petites
questions d'enfants de forme
non c'est vraiment le fun ça crée des
beaux échanges puis là pour le deuxième
volet mais j'ai monté un questionnaire
aussi pour que je puisse récolter leurs
impressions c'est un peu plus tard faire
tourner en classe pour utiliser sur un
outil on peut même pour la suite le
putois temps tout parler est un jeune tu
es maintenant il y avait une ou deux
personnes neurones à l'école
mais est ce que concrètement c'est quoi
le fait que ça lui sur toi c'est ce que
dans le quotidien te faisait rappeler
ceux où ça passe un peu non c'est plus
que honteux rappelle toujours que tu es
différent je vais aller au théâtre que
2000 personnes tu es tout seul noir moi
quand il ya comme une conscience
personnelle de à qui tout le monde en ce
moment me remarque tactique que je fasse
de quoi de bien ou pas bien peu importe
le site fait remarquer toujours un peu
pointé tout du doigté toujours la
personne différente
ça peut jouer sur ta confiance un peu
juste on estime que toujours se
renforcera le des parents aussi
moi je suis métisse donc au québec
je suis noir puis quand je vais au
sénégal ums du toubab ou blanches oui ça
m'a un peu chez vous un peu le pas m oui
surtout tu étais né au québec mais tu es
font ces rappels puis je suis une autre
vie iard avec une dame à radio can tm
disent que cette dichotomie l'a donc de
toujours être dans les deux cas ça c'est
difficile
j'ai dit ben c'est les autres qui
demandent de choisir ses autres demandes
et du plus noir d'être plus blanches du
plu chanteuse et plus animatrice
mais quand toi tu fait la paix avec ce
que tu est étudié un mois ça a pris
quelques années quand même peut-être
autour du cégep
j'ai trouvé que gt gt arrêtés nous
demander choisir je suis une seule une
personne
c'est là que tu t'en bien celle au
dessus tu tues tu vis bien avec tes
origines tes racines puis moi j'ai dû
soit chanceuse parce qu'on est vraiment
eu les deux cultures sur le même pied
d'égalité à la maison mes parents ont
dit qu'ils nous ont donné une éducation
et culture est si jeune sénégalais le
moal ou jetalliance au sénégal affectés
ça fait partie de la personne que je
suis taxé au quotidien mais où aller les
femmes je compte aller me faire regarder
déjà été accrochés shore à sa porte et
l'afro jazz politique ce geste éco
seychelles arros aux seychelles je
partais montréal
c'était vraiment alors si je sais pas je
ne peux pas me scotcher comme personne
ce que je t'ai cheikh à la pointe feu
ouais le floch à montréal bin oui mais
tu es comme personne ouais un peu plus
damas à la force des choses si je
revenais à québec j'ai fondé ma
compagnie mais c'est plus c'est ça c'est
le regard des autres mais des données
dans la foulée des gens qui cherchent
une maille mettant juste en faisant par
exemple un mort suspecte par exemple
sauf que quand t'es juste une remarque
entre leurs différents besoins
pictures aux fouilles ça le demeure
extrêmement lourdes pertes ce petit
moujik l'introverti quilichini trop
basse par des foules
moi je sois même les vêtements avisé je
me retrouve dans un domaine très publie
des images de la télé la musique je
trouve mon compte gif si je me sens bien
la balle mais la prime abord moi je suis
quelqu'un de réservé mais on dit au
point de se voir dicter différente on se
rappelle que je décide comme le prendre
à l'aube avait toujours des micros
bingham
qu'est-ce que vous regardiez c'est bon
on parlait de l'afrobeat satire de sa
mort vit une des premières
l'augmentation de l'afro que je suis
d'avoir buts marqués caché james des
émissions de navier musique plus près la
série qui va générer de départ c'était
juste une touffe de cheveux plus c'est
quelqu'un qui tombe dessus
j'attends que la belle se souvient de sa
marque et son shoot shonda rhimes
pylanimé le jeu le vote de nos
perspectives c'est comme ces tendances
actuellement que d'en faire de même
jeudi pas assagi je portais toujours le
flou pendant quatre ans
j'en ai fait mon fils karim à ma mère
quand même de dire beaucoup de femmes
québec portera pro à la télé ou même sur
scène c'est drôle c'est chez moi j'ai
toujours ça fait l'an passé 15 à 20
heures je porte la faux puis au début
les filles c'est la mode
clavel mode catllar des saveurs vous
changer on était très la retraite dans
les médinas l'hyper une artiste reconnue
comme un mouvement de la chaudière qui
est arrivé dernièrement je vous êtes au
courant mais des épis qui retourne à la
chaux naturelle pays qui connaissent des
fusées les cheveux que toute question
d'identité aussi que peu à peu près de 5
10 à 5 ans avant le juste ici on sent un
peu plus mémoire jeunes il ya quinze ans
je disais que tu étais pas coiffée avec
comme quoi cette valorisation la du
cheveu naturel jeu physique il fallait
tout de suite essayé repas c'est quand
même impressionnant pour enfants ces
gens l'oublient pas cette expression qui
est elle standard de bonté six mois
passés jamais autre chose en restant moi
même des fois je trouve que comptable a
démarré je me lève je n'avais pas la
confiance riches placent en tête le 100
m
c'est une part l avoir peur mais nous
aussi
j'aime ça casse mais c'est je trouve ça
vraiment cool de cette personne cette
façon de voir sa différence comme ça
merci beaucoup mais j'apprécie je pense
que il ya un rôle dans l'éducation si
mes parents ont eu un coût comme appui
al-cham quitté new profondément tous les
bons coups tout le monde veut voir
priver le goff et qui tu es pour pour
après bien avec toi même comprendre que
kannad verte issue du chef problème
disent pas petite question c'est quelles
différences à jour depuis un peu pour
tous est pareil pour nous apprendre des
autres et en outre une famille sur
l'ouverture le mans je peux dire qu'on a
toujours eu une vie l'environnement avec
déjà un peu partout dans le monde même
si on était au québec qui était quand
même comment une nounou relation et je
pense à l'excitation de jeu dépend pas
de moi l'histoire des noirs qui se fait
au canada depuis combien de temps que ça
se passe là mais tu tiens alors qu'un
style manga aux états unis encore plus
loin et puis qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des enfants
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
connaît pas l'histoire de noix ou canada
aux oscars est quand même différent de
celui des deux unis merci en fait mais
je pense qu'on a connu juste parce que
vraiment c'est nous je me souviens pas
la marque par la même personne pour nous
parler de son site web
ça lui permet de maintenir cet hymne
mettons actuellement ce que ça fait le
moins sportivement je pense qu'on a un
devoir de mémoire politique se rappeler
un peu quitté les formes et les fastes
n'est pas juste blanche de souche et
cette année
le thème c'est voie d'émancipation faire
mal aux femmes ici des voix qu'on a
prouvé qu'on entend pas nécessairement
jeudi entre hommes et femmes le travail
afin de voir au québec car tu as encore
deux fois je suis actif de gangs au
lycée ça tactile de 7 et comme devant
voici des pôles techniques et leur
donner une voix les femmes en termes
d'effets à gijon 12 femmes qui sont un
des athlètes dans une ferme ltv de fois
je pense médaille mais que ce soit de
commandes john john key merci qui tout
essayé de changer sa télé québec
tellement johnson madame que jean
soixante dix ans et si jamais quelqu'un
va mourir des années 70 ça me dit que
vous la cop15 coiffe le temps qui en
fait une des formations des heures des
hommes formés foule de coiffure à
montréal ça dure 45 cents de même deux
couronnés par le gouverment en général
juste une société c'est des gens font
partie demain 2010 affaire de morale on
connait pas les bras tant que marché
coloris que j'ai des trucs pour pour les
femmes la mode avec des africains
ils échangent en guinée c'est que c'est
l'idée c'est connaître ces personnes là
je pense que plus on se connaît on se
comprend mieux vivre ensemble
je sors donc d'une forme maintenant sur
les wii qui avait un peu datés de rosa
parks c'était paul vais vous donnez nous
sommes en sécurité avancée a donné 40 et
très longtemps oui mais ça rappelle que
ce genre de choses n'existe aucun des
grands pôles
je pense que l'été j'imagine pour les
conditions des normes milieu qayyum sens
quand même temps les guitares à sinjar
sapho weeks islam visé mais oui mais il
ya une chanson je demande de plus à
plusieurs chansons - le premier noah au
québec
c'était à rester l'interprète de saluer
le champion pour une raison x parler les
langues
n'écoutez pas ce qu'il va en avril au
musée des beaux-arts
c'est une émotion enfin sur ça s'appelle
fugitif mérité les règles ne sera pas le
québec pour dessiner les désespoirs des
affiches des savanes
comme les cinq représentations qu'on a
des scores nouveau vraiment dans des
lycées ça donc je pense m
des scores de tu vois d'où ils viennent
comme elle pesait comme une barre des 6
avec des illustrateurs de québec
mais moi ça m'intéresse beaucoup le
essayer de juste d'ouvrir la discussion
va se passer de cette histoire le nombre
d'immigrants complètement injuste le
fait c'est que juste défendu de la
métare apporte une très belle chose
parce que l'espace soit qu'ils expriment
ce style moins une soirée noire pour les
prendre notre juste polis noire des
cicatrices qui que ce soit de l'annoncé
respire
tellement que je peux pas tout les
nommer mythes et des réflexions des
tables rondes et les expositions pour
que tu peux en attend justement sur une
fois en dix mois je pense que j'attends
que ceux ci tentent de voir toujours les
crimes du point de vue du concours ici
c'est moi qui ai dit c'est le magnat
c'est en passant par l'édition adaptée
en réfléchisse one management fom bernie
façon qui était prévu des noix aussi les
leurs en fait j'ai besoin que cette
histoire non on l'a 13 encore moins
je pense que je pense que naturellement
même sensibilité pour les réseaux de
télé l'histoire des noirs comme super
ripoli ici paris comme je reprends ma
famille aussi
alors oui il cracha paix pour airplay
ambitions à prendre justement pour des
livres d'école pour moi j'habitais sur
une histoire du jazz qu'est né et je
pense ça va commencer par sophie et les
outils pédagogiques pour convaincre les
jeunes scouts et tenter d'en parler des
livres uniquement paris l'arrivée
l'année 70 sénégal et à ma maman dont
ils ont besoin surtout que c'est tout le
monde se pose c'est si les parisiens de
milieu tellement serré mardi du mois le
sénégal précisément khombole petit
village tu vas que se sont élevées au
dessus pour se créer un monde enchanteur
j'ai pris récemment une émission de
canal 2
il y avait ressorti des vieux vox pop
dans les années 70-80 demander aux gens
de votre fils ou votre fille marie à un
noir et une série d'accords mais à
l'époque est ce que 28 ans miles sans
une certaine pression le jette plus pas
l'intention des liquides ajoute
récemment créée par
mais pour les gâteaux vachon mais par un
coup finalement ma grand-mère était à la
maison mais il y avait déjà un peu
d'immigration qui suit tranquillement et
je pense que ça s'est bien fait chose
que l'extra paraît super voire 70 je me
rappelle une explique ital et mon père
d'une amie annie st gall est tout sauf
un bloc québécois
mais bon on parle de préparer le terrain
que la famille si ça se passait super
bien et mal retourné tout à mais je
pense que la blonde le couple est
reparti sans précédent 70 c'est pas avec
la façon dont on ne sait plus vraiment
qui c'est ça fait que la laine c'est
toujours ce que tu as un film ou un jeu
chose que tu sais si tout charmant de
quelque chose
les jeunes vont en prendre bon franck à
part de cette formalité des gains avec
tes décisions avec ce que tu es avec
avec qui tu es ben après seulement je ne
ressens pas mal et les gens qui nous
fera que jamais ses souffrances et
pourtant banale bon aloi son nom je
pense que ce serait aussi le saab il
était ok qui à l'époque oui puis en bois
du jeu magenties un quartier un petit
peu plus difficile mais maintenant oui
moi quand j'étais à un moine immostat
l'école saint paul à pas contés ras
juste deux mois entre 250 et enfin par
markit après ça je suis allé à brébeuf
piste est le début des vagues de grâce
on tire on est ok monday ses camarades
plus mais pas comme ça mais c'est drôle
l'année dernière ce n'est pas une
conférence à woerth qui avait 24 à
populaire frange pour une envie
d'évoluer dans le world
il y avait fait la cité parmi les
diplômés transition soit acté plus en
plus font six activités pour que tout le
monde ce qui énerve l intégration qui se
passe qui des deux voies étant toujours
des jeux téléconférence ennuyeux qu'il
communautés culturelles sont nombreuses
mais je m'enferme allez mettons la
police charles beau joueur des années 40
ça m'a beaucoup dans mes cheveux que les
jeunes québécois voient des malaises
c'est une suggestion que j'avais parlé
pas juste pour les non les jeunes
souhaitent pas pourquoi mais je pense
dans sa société d'accueil que ça marche
pour si les jeunes québécois ans qui ça
se peut eux aussi qu'ils accèdent à des
postes comme ce métier c'est pas ça
m'est devenue la question tantôt mais on
en aime passer sur un autre sujet mais
justement ces jeunes eux qui voient des
modèles différents des modèles qui ont
constamment ça doit vraiment favorisés
au will plutôt l'acceptation dans son
bilan moral mais aussi avec un parieur
de l'oral
oui c'est vraiment facilité c'est un
masque wiki les enfants sont beaucoup
plus ouverts des oiseaux sur les adultes
mais avec alors là on dirait dans une
classe c'est ma fille n'est pas
forcément je savais que wyeth avec
attend les japonais eux naturellement
c'est des enfants qui jouent au yoyo ce
réflexe nous ce préjugé l'eau qu'on ait
une idée préfet quelque chose qui
pourrait nuire à la relation
explique moi je crois beaucoup à la
jeunesse a beaucoup qui sait locke ou
même énergie puis mais nous vous
donnerons pas ce que c'est vous qui vont
nous sauver c'est hurler couverture qui
lors de leur vie n'ont pas d'idées
préconçues
pourquoi lui souhaiter de leurs
différentes en gros ça veut dire que son
plein et que je pense que mollement
quand j'étais jeune en fait j'ai
longtemps pensé que le racisme c'est
parce que ses maîtres mots quand j'étais
jeune je m'étais jamais dépendu de
propos racistes le pt le beat meiner
lieu paisible et s'il faut que tout le
monde et tu t'égares un peu importe les
propos n'est pas de quoi payer l'école y
avait quelques zones si la vérité
alsatiques quelqu'un nous sommes et
c'est vraiment pour beaucoup
commençaient dans tout qui sait tout le
voit menotter pas avec moi
les gens qu'ils y voient un peu
peut-être personne est certain que ce
pilot mêmes atouts selon dorothea on m'a
parlé de l'assist à l'heure où j'avais
jamais vu 2000 radio europe 1 a vu de
mes yeux tu es vraiment raciste le tient
clairement là c'est ce que nathan et
quelques insultes et c'est vraiment que
tu sois supporter en question mais après
ce sera grâce à des fouilles je
soupçonne que celui des gens parlent de
l'abbatiale les études de pôle emploi
parce qu'ils veulent en tirer
d'ailleurs ma mort mais non en fait une
pièce de théâtre d'accord je pense à
concordia moi j'ai des amis j'aurais pu
s'échapper par le turmel six étudiants
d'origine afro ou merci contre quentin
les années 70 qui ont mis l'état des
travaux
l'écueil d'une étude est docteur en mode
l'année du passage fait qu'il y avait un
peu de sur les intentions de professeurs
fait qu'ils ont remis les mêmes travaux
mme avec des noms de hockey québécois au
moins 300 professeurs il se souvenait
pas d'avoir vu de jeu se fait vraiment
ce qu'on veut mais finalement être là
visiblement c'est clairement du racisme
est basé sur kiki que fait le travail
dans mon jeu ne nous reste pas sans ce
travail là et qu'ils ont peut-être
c'était des grosses manifestations qui
est rue émeutes et ou percer et on va
peut-être que c'est quand le rapport du
mois le soir des groupes si je pense que
ça ça peut amener plusieurs impressions
même sur absolument certaine chance d
assister même au québec ce jugement des
délits comme quoi comme jeu dès jeudi
le québec n'est pas raciste bien du
racisme au québec ont visé d'individus
mais fou tu comprends ça existe encore
ici c'est plus insidieux c'est l'eau
tiède et les actions
j'ai vu junique sujet du profilage
racial des trucs de l'été en france est
profondément des amis avoir marché de la
police par être pas si je ne jouais pas
d'environnement bon non puis jeudi à
cause des personnes moment il dit en
manque donc tout les invités y avait les
de 30 personnes tunis la seule réussite
et monsieur le temps pour deux mois il
ya des comportements tout comme ça
existe c'est comme ça 50 c'est lieu de
crier haut et fort tout les justifie
tout le problème derrière saurma sa
représentativité
mais une fois qu'on ne passe à cache pas
qu'on est tous à faux par action si les
patrons que on et font l'effort pour
japper mais moins pour l'introduction
intelligent de voir la suite des choses
ce qu'est réellement y avoir un effort
pour laisser sa marque et noir sont un
chef de gang de rue mais qui prend 8,25
à ce que ça spoile mégisserie casting de
faire tes autres endroits parce qu'il
faut pas le noir sont reprendre un
individu parce que si c'est le talent
pour remplir le rôle qu'elles ont déjà
fait beaucoup d'années
il ya eu au caire au bye bye les eaux
grecques ta mort depuis des camps
connaître que blackpool
ce france c'est de la folie pitié
enlèvement
c'est donc très gérable bt je suis
certain qu'ils aient aucune des
personnes à ce tableau est activement
socialement politiquement comment est-ce
que ça pète au redoutable car tout le
monde dit se bat il faut graver tout le
monde avec aucune connaissance mais tout
le monde hormis ces hauts lieux du monde
qui on laisse des s'accepter comment
excuser comment est-ce que ça pète tout
si ce chemin le sens quelqu'un fin le 20
ou le petit je vois revenir sur scène
afin que consultant il leur dit si on
quand ça va sortir ils vont voir que
vous avez des datas chanteurs sont
blancs chier interprète des esclaves en
chambre des charitables ça marche folle
je vous dis pour gérer l'animation c'est
le cas particulier parce que les
particuliers le week-end très complexe
pour tous les sens vraiment dans le coup
pile dans les rues des mots qui
deviennent des normes de la société il
ya un débordement de tous les temps en
puissance depuis le ca fait que ça
déborde
d'abord elle est critique les
débordements point critique est vraiment
la chose dans un film mais dans tout en
calmant la personne que le mieux réagi
dans cette situation le si robert lepage
demande quelques hommes éviter se
prononcer de suite dit qu'ils avaient
des critiques les entend asseoir une
tamisée pour me traiter comme devant la
gêne un certain si sensible aussi tissé
de la visée des bonnes façons c'est très
vite c'est pas dans le jour même source
mais c'est quelqu'un qui
fondamentalement vous voulez pour
envoyer ce message
cela s'est confirmé par les après tout
la ceinture on apprend l'art parce qu'on
peut faire et ce qu'on peut faire
bon maintenant ça a été fait je pense
publisac ça tu subis futebol
on ne parle que de la provocation du
tout et je pense même pour tout le monde
c'est exactement ce que c'est la
progression due à quelques questions de
hull de soi mais vous restez doit être
cédé d'autant les gens rapportent que tu
peux poésie ou avait des duels je sens
la seule appréciation culturel bon
d'accord quand son petit rayon d'action
de la part d'autres choses que je fais
souvent des trucs qui sont empruntés à
une culture parce que je trouve ce beau
et j'ai besoin je parlais de jugement
femmes ce temps fargo de feuilloux mais
c'est ça qui a besoin d'un amalgame des
conseils quand comprends tout à fait les
médias s'emballent qui sa dérive du juge
du convoi initial
ces choses à leurs différents d'une
ruelle développé par son chemin
maintenant on oublie un peu on passe à
des fi des risques ça disent que c'est
essentiellement parce que le cas là
premièrement polinois qu'alimenter les
jets les deux titres montent en egypte
ancienne laiterie du elsa grèce antique
aussi s'est fait que premièrement c'est
une culture qui ont le monopole de ces
deux sociétés de capital de 60 ans et si
je pense que ça soit admettons ils ont
interdit les les corps de plus le même
temps la gauche semble que ce sont des
objets sacrés utilise sa part le savent
alors le choix je peux comprendre si
c'est un manque de respect et puis je
pense que l'intention derrière la
chaussée je sais déjà rentrée des petits
groupes et vérifie rien bâti bonifassi
telara la page de raciste et pendant des
maxi des gens sont beaucoup plus à lire
cette cause le que je pense que oui
quand il dit qu'il voulait c'est ça
c'est ça le répertoire musical au sida
recensés mois ggg connaissance des work
sens des chansons qui nous a chanté n'a
dans les champs de coton 15
quittant musique points les gones du
théâtre musical rolling comme un
répertoire musical même titre que mozart
ou beethoven dit gino fermage
mais ça c'est sûr que c'est une bonne
façon c'est une montée que ça mais nous
publier quelque chose que le répertoire
tout étudiant en musique tu lui as assez
performant avec des gens là monsieur
maman c'est pas la pression quand les
escarres afrodescendants sombre on n'a
personne 2 et piano temps de retrouver
ses gamins de gens se soient sentis
capables de jouer et de chanter à
montréal sont pauvres et n'ont plus
active le jugement des patients avec
attention mais c'est tout juste si sage
pilot maintenant ma programmation faut
aussi bouger pour vous expliquer ce que
juste scandalisé toujours compliqué on
pense à nous taper c'est quoi c'est quoi
selon quoi là l'appel à l'action
demain ce serait pas par quel genre de
benno mécanisme soit dans les lits
castet puis dans les auditions entre
autres qui est plus de réel sa part s'il
est resté je sors c'est sûr qu'une sens
des plus grandes qui ont perturbé un peu
plus puisque dont choisir les gens pour
leurs jumeaux qu'ils ont choisi tous
deux choisi lui même qu'il est pour ce
qui peut te donner comme tarder à table
moi je suis une femme petits québécois
mais pas mieux c'est juste que le mali
sont vus sur collectif de légion ne
pense pas moins regardant sur conexpo
bamana téléromans québécois sont
maintenant disposer de leur fuite des
maladies téléroman pour ceux qui meurent
de faim de la société ont été guidés
chargement qui peuvent s'opérer cette
façon là dans une télésérie je pense le
règle oui j'ai servi au centre qui après
semaine sinon tout ce grand déballage
tout le monde s'est parlé à sion a signé
comme neige
un contrôle ailleurs mieux
symantec et je pense que nicolas sur la
crise là où vraiment vachon qui a fêté
ce sont des gens qui s'étaient pas parlé
on a tous développe maintenant mais cela
paraît une bonne phase i way je pense
que les favoris et avec quelqu'un
d'autre en scope mais je pense que c'est
ça va pas falloir dès lors la rédaction
ouest-france concrètement si on met
cassé mon utilité par les réalisateurs
sont de l'adversité reza presse je pars
la solution de tous les cours de cette
rencontre
ton frère christophe monferran par les
tiques plus que j'ai voulu probablement
sa maîtresse le faire pour montrer mon
mur
je pense que ça nous va donc aussi parce
que tu en dis toujours polarisé n'est
pas juste une version blanc leurs actes
peuvent s'échanger ensemble je pense
qu'il ya une plus grande compréhension
mais c'est intéressant car c'est
justement les accords - multidisque et
parce que tellement de gens qui ont jugé
cette situation le cette pièce le sang
et or du sentiment qu'en haïti est
devenu un staff argh prenait ton casque
est plus élevé idéal j oui c'est en
connaissance de cause - ou ses contacts
de l'intérieur du lycée décision qui est
prise c'est en connaissant quelque chose
de là au québec qui moi me dérange c'est
quand il ya eu une espèce de désir de
vouloir mettre des quotas
si on veut le fonctionnement dans une
télésérie j'ai partagé par les
téléséries québécoises suivante et au
québec quatre garçons le film ou une
télésérie et comme le nom le noir
exactement je voulais je suis poli
mais c'est sur ce qui se passe après
puis le lady dior serres castet selon un
rôle technique parce que sa marine
je suis fatigué qu'on dépasse ici tu
subis corps
maintenant si le québec les gens
s'affairent santé oms le fonds des mois
le nombre de productions fait par des
gens des gens montréal déjà initiés vous
animez ce soit des pièces de théâtre ça
soit des tables laurence de cinéma dit
beaucoup de choses qui se font jusqu'au
niveau qui grandit un peu une dame
puisque la même chose qui est pas mal
d'eau chaude le 6 minutes ce jour
celle-ci vous trouvez cas qui a passé
quatre ans il est nommé organisez-vous
pu monter un show mais arnaud mais ce
soir c'est bien toute une
le dialogue soit fait à mon projet c'est
demain m'intéresse à tout ce qui se fait
peu importe d'où ça vient mais bon
montréal au québec mais yo gotti les
communautés 7e du reboot choses qui sont
justes on est plus amoureux multiples
différence québécoise qui mettons notre
forme actuelle suspense qui fonctionne
ce que pense que les gens se commit des
cassés ou si chacun déshabille pas dans
son coin et convient à petit je te
laisse je reviens à lisa turquie en
famille chez les adultes on apprend des
racistes et mes craintes quant à une
toux et c'est la reconnaissance des
diplômes dit il
le gain de la manche par est activée il
y en août rôle d'eliza semaine qu'il
portait sa maîtrise dans le magnifique
sommes partis s'ils arrivent parfois
l'empathie c'est tous des arbustes qui
fait en sorte que tu arrives pas au bout
ce que tu veux d'abord qui me gratte
c'est l'arrière ton sens de jenson
choisir nouvelle taille fait les adultes
en haut du chemin à faire mais c'est
beaucoup de mobilité vraiment place qui
je compte dans le remplacement était
pour cette version david continuation de
nos performances appréciables pierre
texte sinon dans les écoles avec les
jeunes on veut l'avoir quittée les
jeunes y partage échange d'une preuve
que dix pays les champions aucune autre
comme ça parce que le bassiste richard
wooding l'ouverture fait est-ce que
en tant que société l'énergie de la
bonne façon ouvert la bonne direction
estime exprime bien est ce que au moins
autant d'énergie pour la jeunesse que
pour essayer de changer les mentalités
en ce moment au québec
je pense que
je pense qu'on a des vieilles mentalités
bien ancrée - je pense qu'on n'est pas
assez sur la jeunesse aussi ce que je
m'efforce de faire parce que c'est là
demain ceux qui vont nous sauver c'est
ce qui donne espoir c'est qu'ils vont
construire le québec de demain qui sont
vraiment le visage de demain geste et on
a refusé la commission sur le raciste
systémique si au québec on veut pas se
faire dire que du racisme ici comme on
veut pas se faire dire que liliane de
rue on me pose tout cas pas
d'islamophobie
t quand on est à trois jours de la
tuerie de la mosquée des déclarations
comme si je sais pas dans quelle qu'elle
rêve vous vivez là où mais je pense
qu'on on you de quad ancré profondément
qui prennent ou c'est ça qui freine les
vrais changements qui peuvent aller de
son travail far rabat a au fond que
certaines choses changent dans les
mentalités dans la façon de gouverner ou
des priorités finalement comme un
coffre-fort que ce qu'il faut faire mais
dans le temps de jeu est mon ami il y en
a eu au gouvernement dans le temps qu'il
y avait des belles il y avait des
meilleurs louables des meilleures
mesures pour l'immigration apparaît
visible c'est difficile de trouver un
emploi trouve un logement trouvé une vie
adéquat ça rebute un peu ça crée des
tensions puis la reconnaissance des
diplômes baisse à 7 décourage un peu
c'est ça c'est clair c'est un vrai grand
amour propre ton pays tu arrives ici
pour de nombreux prophètes pas réussi
c'est ce qu'a fait pareil parce que
parfois la tactique c'est un gros
problème encore qui super actuelle est
que je pense que des meilleures mesures
pour l'immigration c'est que c'est
bizarre c'est que défend les pressions
comme je parlais avec somme on parle
qu'on avance on recule et qu'on avance
york et la mosquée et avance la presle
et reconnaissance des diplômes non
l'occupation du gang des choses mais on
recule aussi du fait que les spurs pas
donné mais j'espère me gêne aussi je
dirais c'est la mosquée en même temps
doit être quelque chose d'absolument
effroyable qui fait par la vague d'amour
qui a eu après donne confiance s'est
fait cueillir comme ces deux affaires le
claironne avec lui
quand même une enthousiasme dans la
ville si je j'ai quand même espoir
beaucoup puis j'ai je suis positive dans
ce sens que je pense qu'on s'en va vers
le mieux je ne dis pas qu'on se mettre
la tête dans le sable c'est déjà tout
est bon d'entendre à la télé puis on a
su présenter vous faut quand même être
conscient de la réalité
ouais ouais c'est clair est-ce que
caisse pour revenir au moins de
l'histoire des noirs parce que je pense
que c'est un bon c'est un bon fond avec
ce que tu disais de la culture qui se
fait mais qu'on la connaît pas est ce
qu'il ya des façons
durant le mois de février pour que tout
le monde qui nous écoute puis même nuit
on puisse découvrir davantage sur ce
c'est quoi les meilleurs sur les
meilleures fins d'une meilleure façon
les yeux beaucoup de chance je rigole
vraiment les autres mais il table et
tables noires conversation noir 23
février samedi 23 février moi je suis
lâche sur le panel différentes
réflexions sur on en est où en tant que
société puis par rapport justement le
multiculturalisme au québec mais en tant
que femme noire où on est nous défient
la fac c'est quand même intéressant
parce que plusieurs personnes de
différents secteurs qui vont être là
qu'on discute puis devant public face à
ça permet de découvrir aussi les gens
gala dynastie qui est la troisième
édition du gala qui est la
reconnaissance des cultures noires
l'année dernière soit à tout suspense
angelo cadet que fait la mise en scène
cette année ses proches de la
banqueroute qui a un qui anime ce rôle
oui puis ça c'est vraiment la
reconnaissance de toute la culture noire
au québec
fecteau meilleurs athlètes meilleure
animation à la télé meilleur vidéoclip
représentation étrange image avait gagné
l'année dernière d'ailleurs récemment
vraiment l'étendue des dégâts le même
sort que pas besoin que jamais entendu
ce gars là je n'ai jamais jamais jamais
tout
mais ça c'est la première fois c'est
avoir la troisième et leur fils ait été
si tu vois les réalisations des prix
hommages des votes un des fondateurs du
festival de jazz qui étaient là de douze
familles on a fait un grand hommage à
lui comme un des grands du jazz à
montréal les meilleurs j'ai du meilleur
athlète les entrepreneurs les meilleurs
blogs fatigue
il ya beaucoup de catégories qui reprend
comme l'ensemble de ce que les cultures
noires apportent au québec c'est une
bonne façon de malfaçons commencé quand
on regarde les gagnants regardez nos
mais bon c'est vraiment cool point que
et quoi d'autre j'ai essayé de
l'éteindre la bonne façon si comme à
montréal où partout au québec qui s'est
étendue quand même pas mal
québec qui ont des programmations je
connais moins mais je sais qu'ils ont
quand même chose qui sont ya de quoi qui
sont très coquet auquel moyens qui c'est
très important pour le moins souvent des
noirs si le don de dieu parce que
l'anémié falciforme j'essaie de me
l'expliquer les skis la bonne façon elle
entreprend d'accord personne sur dix
afrodescendants tôt le jeune danny me
fassih fond puis donc c'est une maladie
génétique et pour contrer cette maladie
le sait faut avoir un don de sang donc
qu'est du même la même souche pour
milliers de raisons dans les dernières
années les noix on peut donner beaucoup
de sang mais pas une question de culture
des fon question de rituels à
l'extérieur pendant trois mois tu
côtoyer tous les citer quelque chose
qu'ils ont fait en sorte que les noirs
d'impôt beaucoup de sens donc c'est
problématique parce que vraiment pas
beaucoup de banques de sang pour cette
maladie là avec le 16 février
moi je veux donner du sens et pour la
fondation de l'anémié falciforme fait
qu'on évite les touts les
afrodescendants à venir en donner parce
qu'un manque puis c'est la seule façon
de pouvoir venir à bout de cette maladie
loeb et c'est avec à des dons de sang
des gens de la même souche
oui oui bon bah perso c'est l'argent qui
s'y dit oui c'est intéressant se fixer
c'est une personne sur dix fait que les
gènes et c'est dur c'est pour ça que
le don du sang est nécessaire de la même
souche puis de la même famille mais
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont été très
populaires chez les communautés noires
de donner du sens c'est quoi les
symptômes que ça il ya çà çà çà que
ouais ouais c'est ça doit jouer dans le
style années miss et les globules blancs
le bus rouge c'est pas dans 175 2 x 90
me we keep cool dit non mais tu aura pas
de musique quatrième album quatrième
album oui puis comment ça va ça va c'est
la même chose si je me dis toujours bon
je suis prête leur forfaiture non mais
c'est mon septième
j'ai fait quatre avec ses trois sets
avec ses 20 de bio chem en quatrième je
suis back to de baisers que je retourne
aux sources en effet pas celle que je
viens et je suis rendu compte c'est là
je viens avec mon frère avec toutes les
filles que j'ai fait les milieux où j'ai
été le dernièrement j'ai collaboré avec
mon ami sodja connaissez-vous selon le
rapport préféré puis on a fait une
collaboration ensemble sablier avec easy
est ce qu'on voit là millions de vues
sur youtube ouais ouais c'est une
chanson que j'aime beaucoup cet art gold
j'aime beaucoup puis on a comme une
belle énergie ensemble et je l'invité
sur mon album j'ai fait une chanson avec
lui qui mon frère aussi changé super
engagé qui s'appelle gogh ou gadget
les policiers se retrouvent et
d'accessoires et je retourne à ses
sonorités là c'est claude bégin mon ami
claude qui est la bonne pour icloud
c'est un espèce de réalisateurs
incroyable fou on avait sous la clause
toutes les pelotons se passe dans la
location
on a mis nos différends je te fais
toujours de faire aussi les sommes en
jeu
non mais c'est faux vrai atypique lot de
thé pour ceux qui connaissent ce jeu
sans guillemets en tant qu à la claude
pingat chess écrite à tous ces possibles
aux lakers accrophone réservé que c'est
carrément mal est fait les albums à mon
frère aussi moi ça fait 15 ans qu'on est
des amis puis c'est sur notre avis sur
tout mais toutes les fois que je peut
l'attraper j'attrape peugeot voit la
belge poser de l'attraper le joli coup
qu'est ce que ces jours-ci pendant la
préparation
moi c'est ainsi je suis scotché sur
l'afrobeat j'écoute du risque et dzeko
de mr easy
qu'est ce que j'écoute le chignon chenal
j'écoute begin et un fou complètement
toujours un peu mais je suis bon dans la
phobie j'aime beaucoup ça ouais j'ai
ressorti cette semaine j'ai ressorti du
shanxi sa vie est tellement la wii c'est
la belle voix mélodique qui comme taille
pirate bay chantera moi je moi je l'aï
redécouvert imagine que le chant les
chances lâchera pas ça me parle c'est se
passe quelque chose dans les quelques
chanteuses thérapeute c'est comme si tu
n'es pas this way sait que ça va être
by pop dansant comme toujours mon
affaire normalement quelques singles au
printemps puis l'album à l'automne
prochain
ce culte est-ce que tu embarques dans la
mouvance sonorités mais d'autres
chapitres courts
je suis bête trappe
je travaille aussi que farfadets quitte
c'est lui qui a beaucoup fait de l'ebit
de soja en route qui était l'adjoint de
la musique avec rhymes de la meilleure
nom d'artiste par fede est vraiment
talentueux puis chypre avec lui
facturent des fois il ya un peu il ya
même sonorités actuelles mais moi je
suis vraiment plus vers l'afrobeat ni
qui plus dans son cas c'est d'abord
l'identité tant que femme noire née à
limoilou l'identité puis ça me suis
toujours si c'est ce qui fait que je
suis en fait je raconte mon histoire à
travers mes chansons l'amour que moi
j'aime l'amour
j'aime les mets l'amour figé des jumeaux
de 6 ans beaucoup d'un mot texto l'amour
de soi aussi
puis en tant que femme 30,6 en mer
entrepreneurs artistes animatrice
journalistes ou publicités l'ont fait
que l'amour de soi ça fait stimule le
fait de stenay 1/2 ce qu'on fait de jeu
placer ses thématiques l'oci limoilou
jamais très loin dans mes inspirations
aussi et que ça ressemble pas oui
exactement une date le d'albums - c'est
quoi c'est vraiment c'est comme quand tu
regardes la musique de québec
iovine incarne ça existe le bain quand
commencer à énumérer
de webster karim claude déjean qui les
codes de ouais je vous en parle tout
cela n'est pas parce que l'eau c'est
lucie jose à l'époque si vous étiez yami
no
c'est lionel donc on avait travaillé
ensemble yocum de quoi je sais pas si
c'est un sens une solidarité sentiment
de famille
ouais parce que ce monde là se côtoient
oui mais bon on était dans le même bloc
10 36 moi j'habitais le sud où est l
homme aux frères pas c'était ça a été
une synergie musicale et capote à 10,36
à québec c'est le genre d'histoire
c'était une descente en quelle année où
il a effectué la création jusqu'au bout
de tes chansons qu'ils aiment celle de
bons résultats oui eh ben on veut pas
j'allais dire que l'audit soit encore là
mais je pense qu'il fut le depuis pas
longtemps par les eaux
têtu et têtu nostalgiques de soude de
cette époque le suis pas j'essaie
d'enlever la nostalgie de matin
quelqu'un qui cumule beaucoup de
souvenirs qui aime et je pense que la
nostalgie se transforme en mélancolie
je veux pas regretter les choses c'était
des superbes années vraiment sur ces cds
amitié de muscat qui se sont formés
aussi beaucoup c'est clos on a fait des
studios que des soirées et des soupers
au travers de la porte alors quitté ses
rangs des beaux moments l'on est
ailleurs puis c'est correct
le magistrat d'en profiter pleinement de
rang les choses arrivent pourquoi les
regrettés jeune fils autrefois j'étais
moi j'ai des jumeaux à 30 ans je dois me
dérangeait pas un mardi soir des chin
tranquille le vol n'avait eu six dans la
manche et des petits partis billy soit
horrible je t'ai ben correct d'avoir les
pieds levés avec non mais c'est l'idée
c'est pas de regret pour regretter puis
d'avancé puis what's next votre mais
c'est cool de voir comment tout le monde
tu ton frère tu ne gagnes pas né de la
dernière pluie le fronton avec l'autre
ap le tuer puis c'est le fun de voir si
le mettons maintenant l'écart ensemble
wester libyenne sur un nouvel album
ainsi tout ce qui s'est passé ou
illégaux sont rendus puis c'est le fun
s'inspirait ça oui chaussé des bouches
cheminement aussi la vie on est tous on
supporte aussi tout le monde
l'adaf à couiza inspire à ses fins de
voir que les gens font sont encore le
patois
oui ces coups derrière il était sorti le
post il entame samedi tourner avec avec
sabrina sabotage à ce petit bon de
sortie en fait il ya un an et demi
sortie de diass yonath que notre projet
avec ses a jailli dancer anglais plutôt
électro dance hall pisam à la sortie
c'est vrai il est sorti son album come
and cher show sur la peau musée non le
khronos ferry dancehall pige pas baissé
mais ton médias les ont un peu électro
dance à dans le style puis sabrina
sabotage sont alors sorti son album solo
cette année je mens le temps au prêt cet
été en fait puis moi je suis sur son
chai sont une chance avec elle et toi
comment tu fonctionnes quand tu écris
une chanson est tombé dans le texte le
tie break un texte avec lou monde jamais
mon propre nom dans la vie on à partir
de la muse et concret en studio je fais
souvent des yaourts qu'on appelle ce
sont juste les mélodies sans les mots
comme coller une émotion picoler vas y
que je veux donner à la chanson
après ça j'amène des mauges écrit des
trucs griffonne je regarde ça avec le
choc ou écriture partant d'un but à la
pause
moi c'est surtout lui fait des bétons
auto train blouin fait bob bouchard
s'est beaucoup lui qui fait toute la
production puis on travaille on subit
claude cela fait d âge aussi comme j'ai
fait des nz filet db quand tu vois on
ouvre puis on choisit aussi des fois
certains trucs qu'on fait du séquençage
à travers tout ça puis
c'est ce qu'on essaie de respirer tout à
fait des fautes trouve dans une position
où te de l'amuseur obligé à natation
quand même des lunettes ne vont pas trop
pas trop quelques minutes mais ouai
c'est trop bien avec ma blonde
on essayait fabricant français puis on a
eu vraiment d'hamza la musique pop en
français sans fautes bah oui c'est pour
ça dit-il dans ce qu'ils ont réussi
afin de la musique pop est temps que
dans le forez sans que je pense à karim
rire et mollet depuis la lester pas un
plomb que d'autres les meetic est
vraiment que ça a marché à fond la
caisse pitié je sais pas si c'est la
maturité du 7e métier je me dis le jeu
juste faire de la musique qui me plaît à
mon goût pour être en français exc ça me
faire des attentes qui la radio kiss
hausse à ses portes lundi juste faire de
quoi de bon que j'aime mais
effectivement faire de quad deux buts
dans cinq ans si c'est toujours un défi
scientifique ça devienne cheesy j'étais
plutôt un texte vide de sens serait
peaches et patti smith un défi de faire
des textes yen qui me ressemble qui ont
conquis pas de sens mais parallèlement
burghardt avec des astronautes c'est
notre projet de loi et qu'on l'on fait
vide ses côtés pour bouter truc dans le
fond c'est une sonorité d'abord ce que c
est la musique d'abba
pete est un anglais je pense que ce qui
marche en pop si que même si tu entends
pas comprend pas les mots il ya des
choses qui poussent à la technique du
yaourt de vraiment chanter des choses
que tu entends sur le b et ensuite
placer les mots pour pas être pris dans
le monde pour dire absolument le mot smr
le autre façon de trouver ce sens là
mais que ça coule un peu plus de
personnes y sont invités le moment si ce
n'est ce pas le lot c'est que des
restrictions qui te force à prendre des
choix créatifs points exactement moitié
pour l'écriture c'est une bonne façon
d'une journée à partir d'une page
blanche la page
ouais mais tu apprends une fois
l'anglais ou si étonnamment français
j'emprunte à l'anglais par moments je
pense oui je sais donc pas chaud face à
travailler un texte un peu mais c'est
principalement français ouais aux
festivités comme non cool et merci de
18,6 c'était un plaisir et toutes les
informations pour eux oui toutes les
affaires vont être dans la description
de la vidéo ici
magnifique tableau des malades à cause
de sa housse fausse mais il ya beaucoup
d'activités beaucoup d'entrevues moi je
fais beaucoup d'entrevues sinon mais
j'ai le reste de la vie qui continue à
rouler des jumeaux c'est un bon quand tu
regardes tes enfants avec elle est
exactement
merci merci c'est gentil